>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[silence]
>> JOAN WEEKS: So, good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of all my colleagues,
in particular, Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and
Middle East Division,
I would like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the Near East Section
and the sponsor of today's program.
We were very pleased to
present this program to you
on Islamic Architecture and its
relevance to daily human needs.
But, before we start
today's program,
I'd like to give you
just a brief overview
of our reading room
and our division.
This is a custodial division and
it's comprised of three sections
that build and serve our collections
to researchers from
around the world.
We cover over 78 countries and
more than two dozen languages.
The Africa section includes all
of the countries of
South Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic section covers
all of Hebraica worldwide
and the Near East section covers all
of the Arabic countries
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
Afghanistan and the Muslims
of Western China, Russia, and the
Balkans, and both of the Caucuses.
You can see how expansive
our coverage is.
After the program, we'd
like to invite you to fill
in the little evaluation forms
we've left in your chairs.
This gives us an opportunity
to see how you
like the program and evaluate them.
Also, we left little flyers in
your seats about our 4 Corners blog
and if you sign up for the blog and
our Facebook page, you get to hear
about our future programs and also
see some very interesting posts
by our curators.
We would also let you know that this
program is being videotaped so that
if you ask a question at the end,
you're implicitly giving our
permission to be videotaped.
And after the program, we
have a lovely surprise.
We'd like to invite
you to a reception
in out Northeast Pavilion
behind here.
And we want to thank the
Egyptian Embassy for providing all
of the wonderful food and drink.
So, now I'd like to
call upon my colleague,
Fawzi Tadros to introduce
our speaker.
Thank you.
[pause]
>>FAWZI TADROS: Ladies
and Gentlemen,
Dr. Heba Abdelnabi received
her PhD through the University
of Alexandria Egypt in 2004.
She received the Fulbright
Foundation's scholarship
to conduct research and
teach at Marymount College,
Virginia in 2007 and 2008.
There, she taught Islamic
art and architecture.
Currently, she is teaching
Islamic architecture
at University of Alexandria, Egypt.
Dr. Abdelnabi has published
a number of research papers
in numerous national and
international journals.
She has published a number of
books on topics related to art,
architecture and social
life during the Islamic era.
She held a number of administrative
positions- an executive manager
of quality assurance unit and
she is currently vice dean
for graduate students and research
at the faculty of Alexandria.
Dr. Abdelnabi will be speaking
today on the various structure
in Islamic architecture
including religious, military,
residential, and commercial.
Dr. Abdelnabi is a member
of the Islamic art historian
of the United Kingdom, the
Middle East Association
and the Arab Historian Association.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Abdelnabi.
[applause]
>>HEBA: I'm really honored
to be invited today by
the Congress Library.
Together, I mean the African
and Middle Eastern division,
in collaboration with the Egyptian
Cultural, and the Egyptian Bureau
to give a lecture about
Islamic architecture.
So I'm very thankful to Dr.
Fawzi Tadros, Dr. Maidi,
Dr. Muhammad-Hamsa,
and Dr. Megged Said.
Today the lecture will be
about Islamic architecture.
Actually it will be like an
overview about Islamic architecture
from the 7th till the 18th century.
The aim of the lecture is to
answer two main questions.
The first question is:
were the buildings designed
to meet the daily life
needs of the people,
the Islamic architectural buildings?
Were the buildings also designed to
meet the needs of the environment?
Those are the two main
questions I intend to answer,
or to try to answer today
during this lecture.
I thought it would be helpful to
start with the chronology of Egypt,
the chronology of the
Islamic era in general.
First, to show you where we
can see Islamic architecture,
and so when can see Islamic
architecture in various countries
in the Middle East, and in Asia too,
like India, and China, and Pakistan.
But actually I will be
focusing on Egypt in particular,
because most of the examples I will
be presenting are about monuments
or buildings, Islamic
architectural buildings from Egypt.
So, I thought it would
be useful to start
with telling you the
chronology of the Islamic era
in Egypt, which was Egypt was ...
can't hear me?
... Egypt was opened by
the Arabs, by the Muslims,
during the Rightly
Guided Caliphs era.
And then it was ruled by the
Umayyad, and then the Abbasids,
and during that era it was
ruled by the Tulanid era
or the Tulanid Dynasty, and then
it was followed by the Fatimid Era,
the Ayyubids, and the
Mamluk and the Ottoman.
So, I will be presenting
examples from those various eras.
Each image that will be presented
has a caption indicating the name
of the place and the era it dates to
and the place of building,
of course.
To start with, I should mention
that Islamic architecture
has many types of buildings.
And those buildings could be
classified into 4 main groups:
religious buildings,
residential buildings,
military buildings,
and service buildings.
And the service buildings,
as we will discuss later,
could include two types of services:
free services, and paid services.
That's why we included
the commercial buildings
in that category too.
To start with the religious
buildings,
I will start with the mosque,
which is the most important
building in Islamic architecture.
The earliest mosque in Islamic
architecture was the mosque
of the Prophet Muhammad
Et El Medina.
But of course, I can't
present an image of the mosque
of the Prophet Muhammad Et El Medina
now, because it does not represent
at all the original
shape of the mosque.
It was pulled down,
rebuilt, renovated, enlarged,
several times through ages.
So there is a drawing about the
mosque of the Prophet Muhammad.
It shows how simple
the building was.
It was like rectangular area,
surrounded with a wall
built of mud brick.
And it had in its southern part a
roofed area which was called Sulfa.
This roofed area consisted of palm
trunks covered with palm branches.
This is the area which was
devoted for the Muslims to pray in.
And when the number of
the Muslims increased,
they added another roofed
area in the Northern part.
So they had two places for prayer.
The rest of the mosque
was like an open space.
Actually this mosque was the nucleus
of the Muslim community
at that time.
It was not only a religious place
where you could perform
the 5 daily prayers,
or where you can perform
the Friday prayer.
It was also the administrative
center
of the newly established
Muslim community.
So, there you could see the
Prophet Muhammad dealing
with the daily issues
of the Muslim community.
It was also a social place.
A place for social gatherings.
They could held weddings, social
meetings, and so on in that mosque.
It was also even used
in during times of war.
They could have like a tent,
in which they could heal the
wounded warriors inside the mosque.
So, it fulfilled many
functions at that time.
And during the reign of
the Rightly Guided Caliphs,
similar simple mosques
were established
in each of the Islamic capitals.
And they were very much similar to
the mosque of the Prophet Muhammad.
And of course they
functioned exactly
as the mosque of the
Prophet Muhammad.
By the increase in number
of the Muslim Community,
that simple building was no longer
sufficient for the Muslim Community.
So by the beginning
of the Umayyad Era,
the Umayyad's had a different plan.
The Umayyad Caliphs had a very
promising building program.
They wanted to have large mosques,
which can be representing the
newly established Muslim empire,
and they can compete
with the other buildings
of the older civilizations.
So they started to
establish huge mosques.
This is an example of
those early mosques,
which is the great
mosque of the mosques.
You can notice how
huge the mosque is.
It is different from the drawing of
the mosque of the Prophet Muhammad.
It was paved with marble; it was
richly decorated, as you can notice.
So it is very much different
from the very simple
mosques in the beginning.
For them it was like the media,
which will be presenting the
Islamic empire at that time,
or the Umayyad Dynasty at that time.
At that time, the plan of the
mosque was very well established.
They decided that the traditional
plan or that plan, or what we need
in the plan of the mosque, is to
be consisting of open court ...
if I use the mouse ...
it consists of an open court
surrounded with 4 roofed areas.
Only the roofed areas
were used for prayer.
Okay? But the open court
is not used for prayer.
So this is the plan that we
will see almost everywhere
in the Islamic countries,
and almost in all the eras.
This is, for example, the
mosque of Ahmed ibn Tulun,
which is the main mosque which
was built in the Tulanid's capital
in Egypt, al-Qata'i,
during the Abbasid Era.
We should understand
how it functioned,
or how the mosque was used.
For the Muslims, they have
to perform the Friday prayer.
And according to the
religion at that time,
they had like strict rules saying
that the Friday prayer
should be held
in only one mosque in each city.
So according to that, that
mosque should be, number 1,
be huge in order to inhabit all
the Muslim community or populace.
Number two, it should be
placed, or should be located,
in the center of the capital,
so it could be accessible
from all quarters of the city.
Number 3, it should have many doors
in order to avoid crowdedness,
and to be accessible for
as many people as possible
who will be praying
inside the mosque.
All of that we can see here in
the mosque of Ahmed ibn Tulun,
and all the mosques that
were built at the same time.
You can notice how
huge this mosque was.
It was more than 6,000
square meters.
And it has 21 doors in all the 3
sides, except for a couple of sides.
And even when they noticed
that it is not large enough
to inhabit all the Muslim community,
they added an exterior wall,
which added an extra
place, which was known
as "Zierd" or " the addition".
We will see that here in the plan.
So we see that the plan of the
mosque became like the open court,
the roofed areas, which we
call at that time "rewalks".
Those are the places where
the Muslims can pray.
Those openings are the doors,
and this is the exterior wall,
which was even added, to add
an extra place for prayer,
which is the zierd, or the addition.
We notice also that inside
each one of the 4 rewalks,
there are rows of columns.
Those rectangular things
are the columns,
which were built inside the mosque.
And they carry the arches,
in order to carry the roof.
This is the first function.
And it also facilitate
organizing the Muslims
into rows when they pray.
What else do we need
inside the mosque?
What should be inside the mosque?
The first thing that should be
inside the mosque is the prayer
niche or the kabla direction.
A place to indicate
the kabla direction.
According to the Islamic religion,
all Muslims have to
face Mecca in prayer.
And of course the direction of
kabla, or the direction of prayer,
would vary from country to another
according to its relation to Mecca.
For example, in Egypt, the Kabla
direction is towards south east.
In Iraq it is towards south west.
In the United States, for example,
it would be towards
east, or south east.
Okay? So it varies from
place to another according
to its location in
relation to Mecca.
So, each mosque has to have
an indicator of the kabla,
in order to help the
people who will pray to know
where to stand and what to face.
The kabla direction was in the
beginning, just a mark on the wall,
which was simple and flat.
But later, the Muslims started to
make the prayer niche in that form,
which is a concave prayer niche.
Why concave?
Because the imam would be facing the
prayer niche, and the concave shape
of the prayer niche would
resonate the sound of the imam.
Another thing, which is very
important inside the mosque,
or specifically inside the jama.
The jama is the congregation
in mosque,
where the Friday prayer is held.
So it is the large one
that we mentioned before.
The jama should have
a member, or pulpit.
The pulpit is the place where the
imam can preach the worshippers,
before starting the prayer
and it is an essential part
of the Friday prayer.
So they added another furniture,
or we can call it another element,
inside the mosque,
which is the pulpit.
The pulpit as you can notice, is
a raised place, or a raised seat
for the imam, ascended
by a flight of steps.
And on top of that place, there is
a dome, also to resonate the sound.
Not that only, but they even added
another huge dome above the area
of the prayer niche, and the
pulpit together, above the square
which occupies the prayer
niche and the pulpit,
because the pulpit is usually to
the right of the prayer niche.
So they added a dome
above that square in order
to resonate and magnify the sound.
But still, could you imagine
in a mosque as the mosque
of Ahmed ibn Tulun, which I
showed you the picture of.
Do you imagine that the people who
are praying in the back rewalk,
at the end of the mosque,
would listen to the imam?
Would hear the imam?
Probably not, because
it is very huge.
So they probably would
not hear the imam.
That's why they added another
element inside the mosque
which was called Dikket Imobiluh.
Dikket al-mubaligh is a platform,
either made of wood or made
of marble carried on
a group of columns,
and ascended by a flight of steps.
And on top of that place,
there used to be a man
who will scold al-mubaligh, who
repeats whatever the imam is saying.
Here is the prayer niche,
and next to it is the pulpit.
So the imam would be standing here,
and the man, or the al-mubaligh,
on top of the dikket,
would be seeing the imam
and would repeat whatever
the imam was saying.
So the people at the back
of the mosque would hear
him, or at least see him.
How they would see him, this
dikket was located at the end
of the kabla rewalk,
overlooking the open court.
So they would see him
through the open courts.
What else do we need
inside the mosque?
We also need a fountain, which
was usually located in the center
of the open court, in order
to perform a volution,
and to provide drinking water during
summertime, which are very hot,
of course, in the Middle East.
We also need the minaret.
The minaret is a very high
tower, which was built on top
of the building, on top of
the mosque, on its ceiling.
It was used by the Mu'asin, who was
responsible to call for the prayer.
And by that mean, all the
people from all quarters
of the city would hear the
call of prayer, and would come
to the mosque for prayer.
Now we come to the second
building or the second type
of religious buildings,
which is the madrasa.
I mentioned that the mosque
was functioning as the nucleus
of the Muslim community, and
actually it fulfilled all the needs
of the newly established community.
Elementary education was
even held inside the mosque.
You would see things like that.
The sheik, or the imam, would be
sitting next to one of the pillars,
and the students would be
gathering around him in a circle.
That's why they call that system
of education the Halakah education.
Halakah is the equivalent
word to circle in Arabic.
Okay? So they call it
the Halakah education.
So those could be young
children, and could be also adults
who are listening to highly
educated sheik or imam.
This system of education was called
Halakah, was called also rewalk,
referring to the place where
the education was held,
or the teaching was held.
It was also called Zoiah,
because they could take a corner
of the rewalk in order
to have their listen.
Some of the most, actually, only the
large mosques had a similar Halakah,
but for adults.
And that was a sort of
informal higher education,
or informal type of
higher education.
It was free of charge,
but yet it was depending
on that sheik or the imam.
It depends on his time,
his availability.
So it was not established as
a formal system of education.
By the 10th century, the Muslims
realized they needed a formal system
of education for higher
education in particular.
That's when they separated
the education from the mosque.
Or they took the education
outside of the mosque.
They started what we
call the madrasa.
The Suljuks, or the Suljuk Sultans,
are those who started the
building of the madrasa.
The earliest madrasa
was built in Baghdad,
which was called El
Muston Cerea madrasa.
And after that, the Ayyubids
followed the same traditions
of the Suljuks and
they brought the idea
of buildings the madrasas
into Egypt.
So they started- the madrasas
started during the Ayyubid Era.
Salah ad-Din Ayubb
was alone responsible
for building 10 madrasas
in his reign.
And his successors followed
him in the same tradition.
And it became a very popular
building during the Mamluk period
in particular.
The plan of the madrasa
was different from the plan
of the mosque in order to fulfill
the function of the madrasa,
which is different from
the function of the mosque.
What was the function
of the madrasa?
The madrasa, according
to the suljuks,
was intended to provide formal
system of higher education,
and it was also intended to be a way
to stop the Shiite spread
in the Muslim countries.
So the Suljuks intended to teach
the Sunni laws inside the madrasa.
And in the Sunni law, we have 4
schools of thought, which are:
the Shafi'i, Hanafi,
Hanbali, and Maliki.
That's why when they started
erecting the madrasas,
most of them were following
that plan
which we call the cruciform
plan, which consists
of an open court surrounded
with 4 ewinds.
It's not rewalk this time,
those are called ewind.
What is the ewind?
The ewind is like a huge room,
overlooking the open court,
and it opens to the open
court as you can see.
So it could be like a classroom
for a group of students.
By the way, this is the largest
ewind in Islamic architecture
in Cairo, which is the Kabla Ewind
of the Madrasa of Sultan Hasan.
This was visited by
Barack Obama by the way.
It was intended to be the largest
in Islamic architecture in order
to compete with Ikistra Ewind,
which had the reputation
of being the largest
Ewind in architecture.
The madrasa was functioning
as a boarding school.
So, both the teachers and the
students' lives inside the madrasa.
In order to accommodate with that,
the madrasa should
have residential rooms
for both the teachers
and the students.
The madrasa should also
have a kitchen, bathrooms,
stables for the donkeys
or the animals
of the teachers and the students.
Okay? Sometimes even in large
madrasas they had a small hospital,
in order to serve the students
and the teacher living
inside the madrasa.
So it has all the services
they might need.
Actually, I should
mention one thing also.
It was free.
It was a system of education
that is free of charge.
Moreover, it was funded
by the patron.
By the way the patron, or the
person who built the madrasa,
they were usually sultans, amirs,
high officials, wealthy merchants,
or judges, things like that
who would have initiation
to build a madrasa.
And they fund everything.
They set the rules for
choosing the students.
They set their administration
regulations inside the madrasa.
They set how the fund will be
distributed inside the madrasa.
And both the teachers and the
students will get stipends
for being in the madrasa.
They would receive 3 daily
meals, 3 hot meals per day.
They would receive clothes in
the beginning in the beginning
of summertime, and the
beginning of winter time.
All that was more like
incentives to learn at that time.
It was very successful,
especially in the Mamluk period.
How about elementary education?
This was the form of
education for adults.
How about elementary education?
Elementary education was separated
from the mosque at the same time
as the madrasa, and it functioned
inside another institution
which was called al kuttab.
It could be private kuttab, it
could be government funded kuttab,
and it was like a very simple
room, where students gathered
to learn Quran- the
reading, recitation,
and memorization of Quran.
In addition to basics of
grammar, and basics of math.
This is the kuttab from outside,
and the other kuttab from inside.
By the way, my master's
degree was about the katatib
in the Mamluk Era in Egypt.
Of course you notice that
their education was more
like religious education.
Okay? Either in the
kuttab, or in the madrasa.
But some of the large madrasa
provided classes for chemistry,
physics, medicine, but those were
limited and according to the will
of the patron, as I mentioned.
Another religious building is the
monastic mosque, or the khanqah.
The khanqah was built
in response to sophism,
which started to be
witnessed in the 4th century
of Islam or the 10th century.
Again, the building of the
khanqah was created or started
by the Suljuks, and from
them, Ayyubids took the idea
and presented into Egypt.
Sufism is some way or
another close to monastism.
It is a way of thinking
where you abandon life
and just devote your
life for worship.
So the people who are living
inside the khanqah are not working,
so they should have been
funded by the government.
This is a place where they can live,
and they can receive
their education.
And at the same time
they are self-sufficient.
So they would do all the
required work inside the khanqah
without needing anything
else from outside.
The khanqah was following
either the plan of the madrasa
or the plan of the mosque.
But the most essential part inside
the khanqah was the halaweit.
The halaweit are the small rooms
where the Sufis can alienate
themselves in order to worship.
So they were very small rooms, and
it was also just like the madrasa
in terms of regulations
and the functioning system.
So they also have their
own kitchen, bathroom,
everything they might
need of services.
Another religious building is the
mausoleum, or the burial place.
In Arabic, we call it
maktfin, or torbah.
Okay? In the beginning of Islam,
the mausoleum was a separate place
which was usually outside
of the city.
But by the end of the Ayyubid Era,
they started to attach the mausoleum
to a religious building,
either a madrasa or a khanqah.
What is the reason behind that?
Number one, to commemorate the name
of the deceased person in the city
between the people so he could
be remembered by the people,
not in a remote place outside
of the city, that's number one.
And number two, to benefit
from the prayers of the people
who are benefiting from the
free services offered to those
who are using the building.
As I mentioned, the
madrasa was free.
So all the services are
provided by the patron.
So the people, or the students,
would always be praying
for the patron who provided
them all of those free services.
So, in Egypt it would
be very regular scene
to see each mosque attached
with a mausoleum like this one.
And this huge building contains
the burial place of the founder.
They use the place for reciting
the Quran 24-7, all day long.
And the people passing by
the place would be listening
to the Quran being
recited all the time,
and of course that also brings
blessings to the deceased person.
Those are normal scenes
from Islamic architecture
that we can see in Egypt.
Each mosque, each madrasa, attached
with a mausoleum especially
in the Mamluk periods.
Now we come to the second type
of Islamic architecture building
which is military buildings.
Military buildings were witnessed in
Egypt as early as the Fatimid Era.
Only the Fatimids felt that
they need military architecture.
Why? They built the 4th Islamic
capital in Egypt, which is Ohara.
After Al-Fustat, Al-Askar,
and Al-Qata'i.
So this was the 4th capital, and
this capital was the residence
of the caliph, the high
officials, and the army.
So, they felt it should
be protected.
As a result they surrounded the
city with walls built of mud brick
in the beginning, and then
renovated to be built of stone.
And those walls were penetrated with
8 doors that were closed at night
in order to protect the people
inhabiting the city Those walls
and gates were like fortified gates,
so they would look like castles,
or they would like towers like that.
And they were named with the names
that could bring good
luck, or good fortune.
For example, this is the
gate of victory, Belbanash.
And this is Belbatua,
or gate of opening.
So all are names to bring good luck,
of course for the sultan
or the caliph.
During the Ayyubid Era, it was,
that particular era was the epic,
or the apex of building
architecture because of the struggle
against crusades at that time.
So Salah Al Din Ayubb built the
castle of Salah Al Din Ayubb,
which was built on top
of the Moqattam Hill,
in the center of the capital.
And this citadel was actually
divided into two parts:
the northern enclosure wall,
which was built during the era
of Salah Al Din himself,
and it was totally military
in spirit and in function.
But then after the death of Salah
Al Din, some of his successors
like the sultan Al-Kamil, decided
to have the citadel as the seeds
of rulership, the place where
he can rule the country from.
So they added the further enclosure
wall, and they added palaces,
administrative centers, gardens
and whatever they might need.
And it continued to be used as
the seat of the governor of Egypt
since the reign of Al-Kamil
till the building of Adim Palace
in the modern time in Egypt.
Now we come to the
third type of buildings,
which are the residential buildings.
There were three types of
buildings, of course according
to the economic status of people.
On top of those, were the palaces.
Only the elites and
the wealthy people
of the country could
afford to live in a palace.
And then the house, only wealthy
people could afford to live
in a house, but the house
could inhabit a huge family,
up to 400 persons in some cases.
And for the common people,
or the middle class,
they would live in
a place call Rabah.
Rabah is like a large building
with rooms that could be rented,
and in each floor there is a
bathroom, and all the people renting
on that floor would be
sharing the bathroom together.
Okay? This is the residential
building,
or this is the residential
accommodation
for the military class.
The house was very much
similar to the palace,
but it was smaller in size.
So, all the components
of the house were similar
to the components of the palace.
What are those components in
relation to the needs of the people?
We should have an open court.
I think you've noticed that the
open court is very essential
in Islamic architecture.
It is the nucleus of each building.
Most of the buildings
have the open court,
and we will see later
why it is important.
So, the center of the building, or
the house, would be the open court,
and all the parts of the house would
be surrounding that open court.
We need a reception
hall for the guests.
That's what we need
inside the house.
We need a reception
hall for the guests.
We need a sitting place
for the people,
the house owner and
his family, okay?
So this would be call Makhad.
Makhad is the sitting
place in Arabic,
and it is overlooking the open court
so that the owner of the house,
or the family, or the parents,
would be supervising the children
who might be playing
in the open court.
In addition to many other
rooms used as bedrooms,
and they were very simple
in terms of decoration,
except for the ceiling which was
usually wooden ceiling richly
decorated with floral
decorations and inscriptions.
Of course, we need a
kitchen inside the house.
We also need bathrooms
inside the house.
Those are the components of
the residential building.
Now we come to the
fourth type of buildings
which is the service buildings,
and the commercial buildings too.
Here we will be differentiating
between two types of buildings.
Buildings providing free
service, and other buildings
which are providing paid services.
Let's start with the bathroom.
As I mentioned, only the
wealthy people can afford
to live in a palace or a house.
And only those who have their own
bathroom, but the common people,
or the middle class would be
sharing a bathroom with others.
So having a public bathroom was
very important at that time.
And those public bathrooms
were used for all people.
Even the wealthy ones.
They would use the public bathroom.
And they go to the bathroom
at least once a week,
and there they can have
bathing, massage, cleaning,
all the services you could
imagine in the bathroom.
And by the way you can still see
the bathroom functioning in some
of the Islamic countries such
as in Turkey, and in Morocco.
They are still existing and they
are still functioning actually.
The bathroom would be divided
into three main sections.
The first section, which
is called the cold room,
where you can take off your clothes
and take a shower with
the cold water.
And then the second room where
you can find places for massaging.
And then the third room
where you can find a bath tub
with very hot water and you
can have your bathing there.
Of course this is not
a free service.
That was a paid service.
Another service, which
is free this time.
It's the sabil.
The sabil is a place
that provides water free
of charge to any passerby.
This was very essential in
hot countries like in Egypt.
For example, imagine the
temperature during summertime,
and going from place to
another in the hot days,
of course you would need a drink.
So that place would provide you a
cup with cold water free of charge.
What is the sabil?
It's a very simple building.
It consists of one room.
This is the room above
the ground level,
but there is a system below
it which is under the ground.
And the system was
filled with water,
of they can provide their
daily needs by Al Saka,
or the one who carries water
and brings to the sabil.
Inside the sabil, a man used to
work who's known as Misamilati.
His duty was to clean the
sabil, and fill the basin
in front of each of the windows.
Of course the sabil should have
as many windows as possible
in order to help so many people.
So in front of each window
there would be a basin.
The duty of the Mismimilati is
to fill that basin with water,
and to hand water in cups
through the window to the people.
That's the basin, okay?
Another service, which
was offered at that time,
and the architecture was
responding to that need
of the society, was the wikala.
This is another service.
It is like a hotel, but for
merchants in particular.
The wikala could be
seen inside the city.
Again, it consists of an open
court, and it has storage room
in the lower level,
or the ground level,
where merchants can
save their merchandise.
And then in the upper levels there
are rented rooms that could be used
by those travelers
or those merchants.
Similar to this building
was the khan,
but the khan was built outside
the city on the travel routes.
But it has the same plan.
And also similar to
that, is the market.
But instead of renting a room,
they would rent a shop instead.
So that's the market from inside.
Then we come to the
last service building,
which is the hospital,
or the bimarstan.
It is actually a unique building,
because it offered
free medical service.
And the place is open to everyone,
regardless their nationality,
their economic status, their social
status, their religion, their sex.
It was open to all the people,
and it provided everything.
It provided them food, it
provided them the medicine.
Even if a poor patient died inside
the hospital, they would take care
of his burial, and do all the
necessary things to be done.
The bimarstan was following
the same plan of the madrasa,
which is an open court
surrounded by 4 ewinids,
in order to facilitate
the segregation
of patients according
to the deceased.
I think by now we can to a
conclusion that those buildings,
each and every one of those
buildings was fulfilling a need
for the society, or fulfilling
a need for the people.
But how about understanding
the needs of the environment?
Was that also witnessed in
Islamic architecture or not?
Let's see.
We noticed that the open
in the mosque for example.
Let's start by the mosque.
We should have an open court in
addition to the roofed areas.
And the open court was
very necessary in order
to provide lighting and ventilation
for the other roofed areas.
Moreover, the roofed areas
usually have high ceiling
for the same reasons- for
providing lightning and ventilation.
Water was very essential
inside the mosque,
in order to provide drinking water,
and to moisture the
air inside the place.
In the madrasa, the same applies.
Water was very essential
inside the madrasa.
So each madrasa would have
either a well, a water well,
or a sabil inside the madrasa.
They had their own
standards for the rooms
of the teachers and the students.
Each room should have
at least one window,
either overlooking the open
court, or overlooking the street
like this case, in order
to be very well ventilated.
And as for the kitchens, bathrooms,
and stables, they should be located
on the south of the madrasa.
Why on the southern
side of the madrasa?
Because most of the wind in Egypt
is north or northeastern wind,
so the wind will take
the bad smells away
from the madrasa, not
into the madrasa.
As for the kuttab, which
inhabited a large number
of children all the time,
it should be an open place
with so many openings.
But at the same time, its ceiling
would be protecting the children
from the sun during their study.
Another unique thing is the
standards they followed inside
the house.
The entrance of the house for
example should be a bent entrance,
which means if you are standing in
front of the entrance of the house,
you wouldn't be able to see
anything in the interior.
You wouldn't be able to see
the people inside the house.
Why? To provide the privacy for
the people, and at the same time,
to protect the interior of the
house from the dust in the street.
And of course having the
open court would be essential
to provide lighting and ventilation
to all the parts of the house.
I'll have just two minutes.
Another thing which
is very unique also
in the house was the
use of Mushrabaya.
The Mushrabaya is to
cover the windows,
and it is made of turnid wood.
So it is like pierced wood, that
can purify the air which is coming
into the room and at the
same time providing privacy
for the women behind the
windows so no one can see them.
The use of high ceilings,
also to provide cooling
for the reception hall,
which is the hall for guests.
The use of marble.
Some of the reception halls
had a fountain in them.
And the fountain, of
course, was made of marble
and was having running
water in summertime,
also to provide moisturing
for the air in the summertime.
The open logia, or the open place,
the sitting place for the family,
was built in the northern
side of the house in order
to be facing the north or the
northeastern wind, as we mentioned
which was the common wind in Egypt.
Of course, also to be
the perfect location
for sitting during
summer nights and days.
The sabil- they also have their
own standards for the health,
and for the health of the mosomalati
who works inside the sabil.
They had very strict regulations
in terms of the clean linens,
the cistern, the cups, the basin,
and how they provide the
water for the people.
So, all of that to keep the
healthy condition of the place.
They even have a unique thing
which is a small basin below
each one of the windows.
So if you have some
remaining water in your cup,
you wouldn't throw them
or get rid of them.
You would pour them in the basin,
which would be used for
drinking of animals.
The same regulations that applied
in the house would be applied also
in the wikela, and the khan,
which were like residential places
but for merchants or travelers.
And last but not least,
is the hospital.
As I mentioned, the segregation was
very important to reduce infection.
So they would segregate
between the patients according
to the disease they have.
And also they have very strict
regulations in terms of preparing
and preserving food,
drinks, and medicine in order
to avoid contamination
of food and medicine,
and to reduce the infection.
So actually we can conclude
that they understood very well
the needs of the environment.
They understood very well the needs
of the society, the daily life needs
of the people, and one of
the architects in Egypt known
as Hassan Fatri, actually was
inspired by Islamic architecture
to create modern houses and modern
places, who would be functioning
in today, and fulfilling the
needs of the people exactly
as the Islamic architecture
fulfilled the needs of the people.
I hope I didn't take too much time,
and thank you very
much for listening.
[applause]
:
>>FAWZI: Anybody have questions?
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: I think it was
easier for them to build
in rectangular square buildings.
It was easier to handle the
available space inside but this is
in terms of the building.
As for the city, the
normal thing for cities
in Islamic architecture was to
build the round shape cities.
So, the cities would be circular
while the buildings would be
rectangular or square...
Yes, please.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: Yes, sure.
As for prayers- during the time
of the Rightly Guided Khalifs,
women used to pray behind men,
but they were not separated
from the men.
So, just behind them.
But, after that, during the
Ummayid era, we have no record
that they were also
separated from men.
So, probably they would have
been praying behind the men
and it happened like that all the
time probably until the Ottoman time
when we started to see
a sort of a separation
by providing a specific
place for women to pray in-
separated from the place for men.
This is for prayer.
As for education, we have
records of historians telling us
that families were
sending their children,
I mean female children, the girls.
They would send them to private
katatib to receive education.
Okay? So, children, I mean
the girls were also taught,
but probably they were taught
only the elementary education,
so they received only the
elementary education and the
of course those are the wealthy
family only, but the common people
who are in the middle class,
it would be hard for them
to send their girls for- to
receive education in the kattab.
But, during the Mamluk period
I told you that my thesis was
about the katatib in
the Mamluk period.
I realize that during the Mamluk
period, there were some katatibs
for girls only and some other
katatibs for boys and some
of the elite of the society would
continue to send their girls
to a specific sheik or teacher in
order to give them higher education.
So we have records about women
who were reciting the Quran
or telling hadis after the
prophet Mohammed or a famous woman
who were historians so that
appeared but only in medieval times
in Eesef Egypt which
I can tell about.
Thank you.
Yes?
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: Yes, sure.
They are preserved actually the
ministry of tourism together
with the Ministry of Archaeology
are paying or doing so much effort
to preserve those buildings,
especially in Cairo.
We have more than 500
Islamic buildings in Cairo.
You know that Cairo was known
as the City of Southern Minarets
because it chose to have more
than a thousand buildings
of Islamic architecture,
but the number was reduced.
But, they are doing so much
effort to preserve those buildings
and paying so much to
maintain them and some
of them are offering guiding
tours or guided tours also.
But, the problem about Islamic
architecture is that it is mingling
with the community- it is,
if you want to see the
Islamic architecture,
you would go to the narrowest
streets of Cairo and you would go
to inhabited districts
or neighborhoods.
So, it is not in a separate tourism
area, but it is within the city.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: No, actually
they moved away.
The effort of Hassan Fatri,
the architect that I mentioned.
To my knowledge, the only effort
to revive the Islamic architecture.
It happened in a specific period
during the Ottoman period.
There was a revival to the Mamluk
architecture in particular.
That's what they called
newmamlakstein which appeared
by the end of the Ottoman period but
in the modern times, they abandoned
that type of architecture
and they prefer
of course the modern architecture.
To my knowledge, as I mentioned, it
was only the effort of Hassan Fatri
who was trying to revive it again.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: Yeah, we actually have a
problem in Islamic architecture
in Egypt that most of the time,
the architect was anonymous person.
We don't know him.
He did not record his name.
He did not mention anything
to help us identify him.
So, most of the time,
he was anonymous.
Unless we found, for example in
the madrasa of the Sultan Hasan,
we found the name of the
architect and the decorator.
On the minaret of the madrassa on
- on the minaret of iron chaif,
we found also the name
of the architect.
But, those were just a few examples
of names that we managed to find.
Other than this, they
remained anonymous.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>HEBA: Probably yes.
Probably they were
considered as craftsmen,
not like the elite of that society.
So they were not recognized.
Even Sunan.
Sunan the elder and Sunan the
younger had their own architecture
in Egypt- had their own
fingerprints in Egypt.
Maybe by the Ottoman period,
that they paid attention
to mention the name of the
architect and to commemorate him
in history and in architecture too.
>>Fawzi: Thank you very much.
There is a reception right now.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.